Souris former clerk for Supreme Court
justice Harry Blackmun talks about his
book closed chambers dealing with the
Supreme Court confirmation process this
is live coverage on book TV
Koen I'm one of the owners of politics
in prose bookstore and I want to welcome
our live audience here today and also
our c-span audience it's an absolutely
amazing coincidence that we scheduled
Eddie ladder Soros to speak today about
the Supreme Court and then the news of
the the appointment of Justice John
Roberts took place in the same week I
want to welcome ed Lazarus back to
politics and prose for those of you who
don't know he's a Washingtonian and his
parents lived nearby although they could
not be here today it's not a coincidence
that close Chambers has been reissued in
2005 we've all obviously been waiting
for resignations and appointments and
confirmation hearings for some time but
it as I said before it's a coincidence
that it all took place this week and
it's lucky for ed and it's lucky for
politics and prose to have him here and
closed chambers when it was published in
1999 was greeted as a unusual window
onto an institution that is often
mysterious this reissue of the book
contains the original material plus a
new chapter bringing the bringing us up
to date on the last most recent five
years Edward Lazarus clerked for Justice
Harry Blackmun in 1988 in 1999 and is
now in private practice in Los Angeles
he writes extensively for newspapers and
magazines and in addition to this book
he has written one on u.s. Native
American issues called black hills white
justice focusing on the Sioux Nation he
has a new book in the works called
self-inflicted wounds and that's
throughout the year after next it's a
history of the Supreme Court seen
through its
worse decisions it's great to have you
back Eddie and it's great that to
reintroduce closed chambers to a new
audience and I know that people are
going to be rushing out to buy it to
understand what the what's at stake in
the next few months at Lazarus it's an
absolute pleasure to be here
politics and prose and Carla and Barbara
have supported my writing career since
it began
I came to gave a talk here about Black
Hills white justice when it came out in
1991 came back when closed chambers
first came out it's it's wonderful to be
able to call one of the greatest
bookstores in the world my neighborhood
bookstore the yeah and it is of course
as Carla says a terrifically auspicious
moment to be talking about the Supreme
Court it would be enough if it were just
that there was going to be a new Justice
John G Roberts being nominated for that
position by President Bush okay but it's
beyond that
it's it's not just that he's being
nominated he's being nominated to the
seat held by Sandra Day O'Connor who has
people who follow the court know has
been the swing voting justice and most
of the most important areas of law for
the last 15 years or so but it isn't
even just those two things it's also
that this period in the courts history
is really unprecedented in the degree of
power that the Supreme Court has come to
hold over our lives and indeed the
degree of power that we acquiesce it
it's now expected without really much
debate that the Supreme Court will weigh
in and often control most of the more
contentious political and social issues
of our time well right now why the big
question around Washington of course is
is there going to be another nomination
conflagration meltdown of the kind we
saw in 1987 when Robert Bork was put up
to the court
it's too soon to tell whether this is
going to turn out to be that kind of
fight but whether it does or not whether
this becomes a an ugly political
campaign or whether John Roberts sails
through for the first time in 11 years
that's how long it's been since someone
stepped off the court for the first time
in 11 years we have an opportunity for a
conversation perhaps it's going to be a
heated conversation but a conversation
about what the competing visions are for
the Constitution of the United States
and for the role of the Supreme Court in
deciding how to interpret that
Constitution the stakes are very very
high over the next generation this Court
is going to think about and decide
issues that we cannot even imagine at
this point but we already know what a
significant role it's going to play in
questions such as the trade-off between
civil liberties and security in the age
of terror the trade-off between privacy
and the advance of Technology the way
our democracy works our democracy
currently has arteriosclerosis of the
veins every year when we every other
year when we go to the polls for
Congress maybe they're 25 or 30 seats
that are really up for grabs the rest
are all safe seats because of political
gerrymandering that's had a profound
effect on who goes to Congress and what
the nature of our legislature is like
questions of economic justice religious
fundamentalism he's all will come before
the court in the next decade and whoever
gets put onto that court and whoever
remains will have a tremendous task
ahead
right now there's a big prediction game
going on what is John G Roberts jr.
going to be like if he gets confirmed in
Supreme Court in United States and
people are poring over the briefs that
he signed on to when he was Deputy
Solicitor General the United States who
he's represented in private practice
what opinions he wrote in his couple of
years on the DC Circuit I have a
somewhat different approach to the
prediction of what justices will be like
what shapes their jurisprudence most
people when they come up with these
theories come up with very highfalutin
names for them their whole bodies of
literature you know it's a school of
legal realism for example which takes a
very pragmatic view of how justices
decide cases mine has a much less
highfalutin name I call mine the the
theory of interior decoration and and
the theory is this that if you can just
go in to one of the justices offices and
you can look around for a while you can
figure out from looking on the walls and
what they have on their desks and that
sort of thing who that person is and
make a pretty good guess about what the
nature of their jurisprudence is going
to be what their values are and how
that's going to shape the law so I
thought I'd take you inside my old
boss's office for a little bit talk
about what day you would have found that
when you walked into Justice Blackmun's
chambers which was in one corner of the
the Supreme Court building and it was
painted a beautiful blue color which
made certain things stand out even more
in particular the kind of crass orange
Wheaties boxes that he had littered all
over his bookcases now those were from
all the Minnesota teams that had won
various championships and had made it
onto the Wheaties boxes and he collected
all of them okay but perhaps more to the
point on one wall he had mounted there a
full-size baseball bat and underneath
that bat he had a small brass plaque and
it said I shall never forgive myself
and I of course had to ask him about
that bat and what it meant and he told
me the story and the story was that some
of you may know he wrote the opinion in
flood versus [ __ ] which was a antitrust
case in 1975 I believe it was where Curt
Flood who was a very well known very
good outfielder for the st. Louis
Cardinals was challenging what was known
as baseball's reserve system that was a
system that allowed in the the owners to
prevent the free movement of players
before the current age of free agency
Curt Flood wanted to be a free agent he
challenged the reserve system under the
federal antitrust laws and it made its
way up to the Supreme Court Curt Flood
lost and Harry Blackmun wrote the
opinion it's quite an unusual opinion if
you go look at it
the first section of the opinion doesn't
read like a legal opinion at all it is a
tribute to the game of baseball it is
it's just a homily on the greatness of
the game and then it has a list of Harry
Blackmun's favorite players it's quite a
long list as a matter of fact I Witter
White was the only real athlete on the
court at the time this case came how D
of course was one of the greatest
football players of all time
he was so appalled by Blackmun writing
this in Co Miam to the game of baseball
that he refused to sign that part of
Blackmun's opinion he agreed with
everything else I don't know whether
that was because he didn't like the list
of favourite players or what it was but
he wouldn't sign on but Blackmun was
very proud of this particular section of
the opinion and he put it out and the
next day he got a phone call from a good
friend of his in Minnesota and Dan hello
Harry yes read your opinion in [ __ ] vs.
flood fabulous job loved your list of
favorite players only one problem
where's Mel uh-oh what do you mean of
course now lots in my list of favorite
players 511 home runs New York Giants
right fielder had a very distinctive
batting style Hall of Fame Harry's not
there
Blackmon goes to his copy the opinion
leaves through it
sure enough no Mela to which he said the
immortal words I shall never forgive
myself now some people might have been
joking but not Harry black Harry
Blackmun I was shall we say compulsive I
he was extremely detail-oriented I
remember we used to have breakfast with
him every day every workday and we'd go
through the cafeteria line together and
you start your clerkship in July and it
goes to the next July and in about March
or April I'd been working for him from
you know maybe eight or nine months he
turned to me in line and he said Eddie
how do you spell vacuum I said vacu um
well that's right you misspelled in that
memory you sent me last night though you
know I apologized of course a I was
appalled spell checker must have been
broken on the computer or something it's
okay any but you misspelled it in
November too
man was the man was 80 years old and
that's who he was and how did that
affect his jurisprudence well I would
suggest you know Terry Blackman came to
the court as a yeah as a death penalty
as someone who did not see how the death
penalty could be deemed unconstitutional
he was there just in time for Furman
versus Georgia which was the 1972 case
in which by a five to four vote the
court struck down all the death penalty
statutes in America Harry Blackmun
dissented
he wrote a rather agonized dissent in
which he said look I'm not a fan of
capital punishment but I can't see
anything in the Constitution that would
suggest it's not constitutional in fact
of course the fifth amendment talks
about I do process before you can be
deprived of your life which would
suggest that maybe the framers thought
capital punishment was okay in any event
by the by the time he finished at the
court Harry Blackmun had become a
death-penalty abolitionist in fact one
of his last most famous opinions was the
opinion where he said I shall no longer
tinker with the machinery of death well
how did he get from way over here to way
over there one way he got there is his
company his compulsiveness he read every
paper that came across his desk all of
the pleadings in all of these death
penalty cases that came up to the court
over and over and over again
and as a consequence of that Blackmun
came to believe more and more over time
that capital punishment was just beyond
human wisdom to achieve in a fair and
non arbitrary manner it wasn't that he
thought suddenly the Constitution's
ban on cruel and unusual punishment
prohibited this but that the system was
broke beyond human wisdom to fix and it
was because of his compulsiveness that
he came to that conclusion what else
might you've seen in his office well
behind his desk he had the swords of his
grandfather's both of whom fought for
the Union in the Civil War and in
another corner of his office he had
almost a small shrine to Abraham Lincoln
there was a silhouette and
frame quotations and other things Harry
Blackmun was Minh Yin calls was bred
into his bones he was the grandson of
these Union soldiers he had an emotional
attachment to the Union and to Lincoln
that was very very deep I don't know how
many of you read the wonderful novel
Killer Angels about the Battle of
Gettysburg and there's a terrific
section of that book which is about the
Little Round Top the Battle of the
Little Round Top at Gettysburg which
really was the the moment that changed
the tide of the war where Joshua
Chamberlain in the 20th Maine held
against the Confederates and the battle
was won and ultimately of course that
was the turning point in the war and I
remember at another breakfast talking
with justice Blackmun about killer
angels and he literally had tears in his
eyes when he talked about Joshua chin
well what does that mean for
jurisprudence well when you think about
the enterprise of the Supreme Court
under Earl Warren what was that
enterprise that enterprise was the
redemption some people call it the
second reconstruction it was the
redemption of the promises that were
made in the Constitution after the Civil
War in the 13th 14th and 15th amendments
and that's the Equal Protection Clause
the ban on slavery the application of
due process to the States the the
protection of citizens and their
privileges and immunities and someone of
who believed in that stuff for whom
Union ran in their blood on this Court
on the Rehnquist court where the main
and engine was the promotion of states
rights that was never going to be a
court on which Harry Blackmun could be a
conservative and so when people ask the
question well what is it that moved
Harry Blackmun generally speaking from
being a tough on crime conservative
appointed by Richard Nixon in 1971 to be
the Minnesota twin of Warren burger ends
up is one of the leading liberal voices
on the court in late 80s and 90s
what is the explanation for what moved
him
I think interior decoration tells you
the answer to that it was those swords
and that trying to link it
he was a link in northern Republican and
on this court that is a liberal because
it's someone who will have not have any
truck with states rights or federalism
the kind of approach to religion that
this court has that makes him a liberal
and if you want to know the answer to
why David Souter has surprised many who
thought he was going to be conservative
the answer is much the same I can't
remember how many greats it is but he's
it's either his great grandfather his
great great grandfather of David Souter
nominated Abraham Lincoln in 1860 he had
relatives who worked on the Underground
Railroad he and black men had a
connection from the very first day they
met and that was part of it they are
northern Yankee Lincoln Republicans and
on this court that makes you a liberal
what else was in the office he had a
plastic cube on one bookcase that had a
had a swatch of fabric in it and a
swatch of fabric had a hole in that
swatch was from the justices reading
chair at home in his apartment in
Alexandria and the hole came from the
day someone shot a bullet through his
window and hit that chair it's quite a
morbid keepsake actually the idea that
you would cut out the piece of fabric
with the hole in it put in a plastic
cube and have it around the office I'm
not sure what that says about Harry
Blackmun's jurisprudence but I do know I
think what that what that cube with the
fabric representing that was a symbol of
the shadow that really followed justice
Blackmun around after January 22nd 1973
when he issued the opinion in Roe versus
Wade from that time forward he every
public event he went to every speech he
gave he was dogged
by protesters
he received hate mail every week
sometimes many many letters a week
sometimes very strange letters he used
to read them in public eye things like a
deer justice blackmun you are a worse
butcher than Hitler love bill but I and
he also of course received many many
letters and many tributes on the other
side of that issue where women would
come up to him and say that they felt
that he had saved their lives
but that cube that represented to me
Harry Blackmun's constant reminder to
himself of the power of the court the
power of the court to inject itself into
the body politic in its decision-making
the power of the court to affect
people's lives and stir the passions of
people all over this country and all
over the world and I don't think his was
the only chambers where you could read
these things if you go into the chambers
of Sandra Day O'Connor or Anthony
Kennedy you'll see some motifs they're
not not shrines to Lincoln you'll see
Western motifs Navajo rugs Remington
statues these justices are Westerners
and I would suggest to you that their
way of thinking about things it's deeply
deeply influenced by their Western roots
there are two positions in particularly
you could just just to take an example
both Sandra Day O'Connor and Anthony
Kennedy art are deep skeptics of
affirmative action at the same time both
have made very liberal statements and in
Tony Kennedy's case he's written a
leading opinion prohibiting or
inhibiting bigotry against gays what
links these things I think that Western
ISM links these things they do not like
groupthink they have a kind of Western
individualized
sense of the world that you make it on
your own that you should be judged not
by any membership in a group but by by
your character and for that reason they
are very very skeptical of affirmative
action because it represents the kind of
groupthink and at the same time they're
opposed to bigotry against gays because
that also is typing people by something
other than who they are we don't know
what John G Roberts has in his office I
wish I did what I do know just to kind
of change the tenor of things a bit here
is that he's going into an institution
in all likelihood that is troubled in
many many ways it's deeply divided often
it's not just divided it's actually
shattered in the way it exercises power
and it is exercising that power I would
argue on insufficient justification the
basic dilemma in our democracy with
respect to the Supreme Court is how
under what circumstances can nine
unelected people override the judgments
of elected bodies such as Congress or
state legislatures and the answer to
that question I believe lies in the
power of justification that the more
aggressive you act in terms of
overriding legislative judgments the
more persuasive your reasons have to be
and this is a court that has often
fallen short unreason I think I'm going
to take about 10 or 15 minutes to talk
about one particular case and then make
a little last closing remarks and then
I'm gonna open it up for questions the
case I'd like to talk about is a case
that was decided when I was there called
Tompkins versus Texas it's a death
penalty case
death penalty cases are a little bit
different at the court in one in several
important respects but one is that while
you might have one or two free speech
cases a year while you might have one or
two race preference cases might have an
abortion case you might have a religion
clause case you have death penalty cases
coming to the court over and over and
over again every year as someone's time
is running out these cases create a very
unusual pressure at the court and
they've been fighting battles over this
for two generations now inside the court
death penalty cases tend to be
characterized by two things one they
tend to involve a very terrible crime
and the other thing is it often feels as
though something when all went wrong in
the justice system along the way what
happened in Philip Tompkins case well
Philip Tompkins was a borderline
mentally [ __ ] young man a black man
lived in Texas in Houston and he was
driving around one night and he decided
to rob somebody
he wanted to buy dinner for his
girlfriend and the method he was going
to use to rob someone was he was going
to bump into their car and when that
person got out he was going to hold them
up at knifepoint get the money and off
he went so he picked out his victim rear
ends
the car and a woman named Mary Barry 24
years old gets out and and sure enough
felt talking's pulls his knife shouldn't
have any cash so he makes her get into
the car they drive around Houston for a
while while he tries to get an
explanation that he can understand about
how to use an ATM card and finally he's
got it he's got her password and he
takes her out to a remote area by the
Astrodome ties her to a tree sticks a
bedsheet in your mouth and goes off to
the bank
he goes to the ATM pulls had a bunch of
money and we know this because he's
caught like everybody is on the camera
at the ATM and there was also a security
guard there who identified him at 3 in
the morning or whatever time it was yeh
during this period maryberry
choked to death on the gag that he had
stuffed in her mouth it was the kind of
case that gave a lot of us at the court
chills back then it's not true anymore
but back then they turned the computers
off at midnight it was kind of this
mercy that they would let us go at
midnight when by turning the computer
electricity off and we would all walk
out to our cars one by one and drive
home alone and I think particularly for
the women clerks who worked on this case
that was there but goes but for the
grace of God go I quality to it when it
got up to the court
I felt Thompkins had been convicted of
capital murder and sentenced to death
and there were two issues in his case
now I'm gonna go into a sort of Law
School professor mode and one issue had
to do with a precedent called Beck
versus Alabama in Beck versus Alabama
the Supreme Court of United States had
said in a capital case in a death
penalty case you cannot have a situation
where when the jury is deciding about
whether somebody's guilty or innocent
they only have two choices conviction on
capital murder or complete acquittal
they have to be given some lesser
included offense instruction Alabama had
a rule that said no we just go with the
up or down vote and the Supreme Court
said no that's unconstitutional and it
did so for this reason what if
somebody's guilty of a really terrible
crime but not capital murder capital
murder is reserved for a very small set
of really really horrible crimes well if
you're a juror and your only choice is
between convicting on capital murder in
sentencing something someone to death or
acquitting completely there's going to
be too much tendency to convict on
capital murder rather than let somebody
go completely free the Supreme Court
said you can't do that how did this
apply and Philip Hopkins case
Phil Tompkins case as one of might
imagine those lawyers among you thinking
about what his lawyer might have argued
lawyer got up and said yes he was
responsible for Mary Barry's death he
did not mean to kill her he was either
reckless about it or he was negligent
about it but he never meant to kill her
in this country you cannot
constitutionally be executed you are not
eligible for capital murder if you did
not intend to kill so he said not
intentional murder you have to give me
those lesser included offense
instructions trial judge says not not
going to do that I will give you a
lesser included offense instruction and
here's what it is intentional murder not
in the course of a robbery okay now you
see I can see a company all right
nodding your heads here the evidence
wasn't in doubt on whether there was a
robbery or not the evidence was in doubt
as to whether he intended to kill so the
question coming up to the court was well
does any third instruction do or do you
have to have one that comports with the
element that's in question Texas Court
of Criminal Appeals which handles this
thing it said in a very odd opinion that
well he was it's okay because he was too
negligent to be reckless and to neglige
reckless to be negligent so it's okay
it's affirmed what was his other claim
his other claim was based on a case
called Batson versus Kentucky this is
quite a well known case for those of you
who served on juries a prosecution
Batson says well let me back up there
are two ways you can be knocked off a
jury one is a strike for cause you're
the defendants cousin you're off the
other is what's known as peremptory
challenges those are challenges that are
just I don't want this person on the
jury not going to give a reason you're
out of here Batson versus Kentucky says
you can can only you you cannot use as a
prosecutor you cannot use your
peremptory challenges to take people off
the jury because of their race that's
been expanded since then nowaday it
applies to the defense as well as the
prosecution civil cases criminal cases
alike there are other categories not
just race that are involved
back then it was just race in any event
Philip Tompkins was a black man who was
tried from an all-white jury there were
13 blacks on the original jury pen the
prosecutor struck eight blacks for cause
and then used five peremptory challenges
to strike the remaining blacks now that
makes out what's known as a prima facie
case under Batson where and what happens
when when that is made out as the
prosecutor she had to come in and give
race-neutral case related explanations
for those strikes well when she got
around to that stage some problems
cropped up as you might imagine uh she
said she struck one juror because he was
illiterate turned out the record showed
he wasn't illiterate there were some
other things and then the one that got
everybody's attention said she said oh I
struck that one fella because he was a
postal worker and and you know the
question arose well you know why what's
that have to do with the price of eggs
in China and and the prosecutor said why
that bad-looking with postal workers in
the past and but then on
cross-examination turned out she'd
actually had excellent luck with postal
workers in the past so that was a deeply
problematic and that'd dead so the trial
judge had looked at these explanations
and the trial judge had said you know I
don't buy these but I can think of some
reasons why a prosecutor wouldn't have
wanted those jurors on the jury so I'm
gonna say it's okay now as you can see
you're supposed to be evaluating whether
the prosecution is motivated by race and
making up your own reasons is not really
on point goes up to the Texas Court of
Criminal Appeals in Texas Court of
Criminal Appeals are they they picked up
on this and they said AHA trial judge
isn't supposed to be making up excuses
for the prosecutor it's supposed to be
evaluating the prosecutors explanations
to see whether they were basically
camouflaged for racial motive but then
the Texas Court of Criminal Appeals had
said well we're really not in the
business of judging credibility so we're
going to affirm and that's how it came
up to the Supreme Court well most of us
around the court who looked at this
thought uh-huh finally an easy capital
case
we will you know good chance that Phil
Toph is gonna get a new trial
so my oral argument comes around and
sure enough it was quite an interesting
oral argument Thurgood Marshall was on
the court at that time and the lawyer
for the state of Texas got up and
Marshall E about every minute or so
which is leaned into his microphone
postal worker she make argument to
another 36 postal worker and I got
rather unnerving but some of us in the
clerk gallery enjoyed it after after the
argument they go back into their secret
conference and that's how the justices
decide these cases they they go into a
room right by the chief's office and
they sit around and nobody else is in
there and they go around the table and
they vote and one of the justices
justice O'Connor wasn't participating in
this case her husband's law firm was
doing this case pro bono Philip
Thompkins so she was out so there were
only eight justices participating and
here's how the tentative vote came out
at conference five of the justices
thought on the Beck issue that the one
that that the lesser included offense
instruction was okay all you needed was
any third choice for the jury and that
was constitutional three the justices
dissented at that time you could guess
which those three were going to be that
was going to be Blackman and Marshall
and Brennan but on the Batson claim five
of the justices I were thought this was
a violation of Batson and that included
the three I just mentioned Brennan
Blackman and Marshall but also Tony
Kennedy who was brand-new to the court
and justice Stevens in fact Tony Kennedy
after oral argument he had gone back to
Thurgood Marshall's chambers and anybody
who knows Justice Kennedy knows he's a
very likable affable man and at that
time is brand-new to the court and it's
trying to make friends with some of the
other justices particularly ones who
maybe were skeptical of his political
leanings and he'd gone in to see Justice
Marshall who by the way his interior
decoration was quite interesting as well
he had a lot of Kenyan stuff in his in
his chambers cuz he had been
helped write the Kenyan Constitution and
I always thought it was apocryphal but
but there were those who said that that
if you came into his chambers and we
bothering him he would start fingering
the spears he had in there but but in
any event Kennedy went in and he started
joking with Marshall about the postal
worker excuse and how obviously this was
race discrimination and sure enough at
conference there too Justice Kennedy was
and five votes for Philip Tompkins on
that so he was going to get a new trial
all right so what happens then is at the
court the the senior member of the
majority assigns the opinion in this
case it was Stevens because the only two
members who were a majority on both
issues Stevens and Kennedy so Stevens
decide to write this opinion for himself
and he circulates the opinion and when
you circulate an opinion at the court
what you're waiting for are these little
pieces of paper that come sliding under
the door that are called join memos and
they're just little notes from the other
justices that said please join me to
your opinion well you need four join
memos to get a majority because you need
five votes at the court to do anything
in the law up there and so you're
waiting for these four joined memos and
what happened to here is that he very
quickly got his four joined memos on the
backside of the case so he had his five
votes there on the Batson side of the
case Blackmun and Brennan and Marshall
all sent in their joined memos but there
was silence out of the Kennedy chambers
and more silence and more silence after
that and when weeks and weeks and weeks
go by at the court you can be pretty
sure that something bad is gonna happen
if you've circulated a majority opinion
and sure enough after a while Kennedy
sent around a three paragraph note and
that note said I have looked through the
trial record and I can see reasons why a
prosecutor wouldn't have wanted those
jurors on the jury so he had done
exactly what the Texas trial judge had
done he'd come up with his own reasons
instead of evaluating the prosecutors so
that flipped the vote that made it 4 to
4 on the Batson issue
when that happens that part of the
opinion gets thrown into the trashcan
because the Supreme Court does not issue
any opinions when they're tied and it
meant that the bottom line of Stephens
opinion was going to change from new
trial to affirmed on the Beck issue well
justice Stevens couldn't stand that he
was so upset and I think this must be
one of the only times in history that's
ever happened the author of a majority
opinion changed his own mind about what
he wanted to do and flipped his own vote
in the case so that his own opinion
would become four to four and it would
be put in the trash and the only thing
that would come out would be no opinion
at all and if you look in US reports
today you'll see then Philip Tompkins
case it's just one line the judgment of
the court below was affirmed by an
equally divided vote now while that
might have provided a small amount of
satisfaction to Stevens that meant that
Philip Tompkins who was on his way to be
executed and I'll tell you just as a
brief aside what happened a second
habeas petition was filed and a bunch of
researchers at justice o'connor's
husband's firm started looking into
every possible circumstance in this case
down in Texas in a death penalty cases
the jury has to answer certain questions
and one of the questions has to do with
future dangerousness and usually the
state will bring in an expert and that
expert will say oh this person is 100
percent chance of future dangerousness
no matter what death penalty all the way
and the defense will come in and you
know have an expert that will say the
opposite you know with enough therapy
this person safe is safe can be I and in
this case the expert was a woman named
Jean Matthews and they called down to
check on Jeanne Matthews credentials she
had a master's degree from Florida State
University in criminology and she
thought that she had said that she had
known Philip Tompkins from a stint in
jail he'd done in North Carolina and
they called down there to Florida State
sure enough Jean Matthews did have a
master's degree from Florida State in
music she was a trombone expert and the
state of Texas actually ultimately
commuted Philip Tompkins sentence but
I've reserved one thing that we all knew
at the court when this case was decided
in the record of Philip Tompkins case
although it was actually excluded at
trial but in the record was Philip
Tompkins confession Philip Tompkins was
as I said had an IQ of about 75 and he
had come to the police and he had
explained everything that had happened
how he'd rear-ended Mary berry and taken
her out to the Astrodome and tied her up
and put the sheet mouthing down to the
ATM gone back to Mary Barry and she was
dead and you could not read this
confession I've read many many
confessions I was a federal prosecutor
for a number of years I take a rather
skeptical eye to these things but there
are some confessions that have an
obvious ring of truth about them and
this one did it was clear to everyone
who read it and all of us at the court
did that he did not intend to kill Mary
berry which means that constitutionally
he should not have been eligible for the
death penalty after all the man carried
a 10 inch knife stuffing a bedsheet in
the woman's mouth is really not how you
would go about doing it
if you intended and that meant that four
justices at the court were perfectly
willing to see Philip Thompkins be
executed
despite the fact that we knew he wasn't
eligible under the Constitution now
what's the import of this decision now
obviously in this decision I've made the
Conservatives on the court into the
villains in some sense but that's not
really the moral of this story they were
engaged in a reaction against what they
thought was was the completely
unscrupulous campaign that the Liberals
were waging against the death penalty
and there was a lot of merit to what
they were saying William Brennan and
Thurgood Marshall refused to accept
precedent on a single death penalty case
they just issued these boilerplate
statements saying the death penalty is
unconstitutional in all circumstances
basically they were saying my moral
conscience prohibits me from following
precedent of this court and so I'm going
to have my moral conscience trump
president
that's troubling enough because what if
all the justices thought they were free
to do that all the time but it was
especially troubling about it during the
court during that period is when it came
to challenges to Roe vs. Wade those very
same justices of course we're turning
around and telling the Conservatives you
can't have your moral values Trump
precedent you have to stick by row and
so you had a circumstance where the
intellectual capital of the left of the
court had been deeply deeply eroded and
the Conservatives at the court were
responding to that and on this question
of intellectual integrity believe me
they have plenty to answer for - and if
you read closed chambers you'll see
plenty of examples it's too likely to go
into in just a one-hour presentation but
the problem that has come has developed
at the court is a problem of results
mattering over reasons in an institution
where reasons have to be paramount it's
exactly backwards in other words now the
court today is not quite the same as the
court I clerked on there's less
disharmony than there was then but
there's if anything even more how this
is the most activist court probably in
the history United States now by
activism I mean a court more willing to
strike down legislation or more willing
to revisit precedent than any court in
history there are plenty of statistical
studies out there about this but it
doesn't tell you very much
activism is a description it's not a
normative term Brown versus Board of
Education was activist does anybody
think that that was a bad decision no
Bush versus Gore was activist I would
argue that was one of the worst
decisions in history not so much because
of the result it reached although I
disagree with that but because the
opinion itself is so transparently not
right you can't find right it's like
it's the reverse of Roe vs. Wade it's
very hard if you gave truth serum to
people on the Left they're not very many
of them who've mounted
vigorous intellectual defense of Roe
versus Wade they might argue there other
ways to come to the same results and all
kinds of other things but they won't
tell you that it was well reason and I
think on the right you'd find very much
the same thing with Bush v Gore how can
you have a court 5-4 deciding a
presidential election on a decision
that's transparently inadequate and
those are the kinds of questions that
the hearings that are upcoming have to
be about the question of question of
when is it appropriate for nine
unelected justices to superimpose their
views or at least their interpretation
of the Constitution over those of the
elected branches that question is as old
as the Republic it was first given a
tentative answer in Marbury vs. Madison
where John Marshall said the Supreme
Court was the ultimate arbiter but
Marbury vs. Madison involved a statute
where Congress was giving the court
itself more power than the Constitution
allowed and and so some sense in some
sense Marbury vs. Madison is really only
about the Supreme Court deciding what's
constitutional and what's not as the
ultimate arbiter within its own sphere
today we go way way beyond that and so
the questions we need to ask John
Roberts and the questions we need to ask
the eight who still are up there are in
how are you going to justify what you do
and if you don't do it well what should
we as a democracy do about it thank you
great talk I know you'll all agree with
that the the mic is in the middle you
must use the mic for your questions I'd
like to start by asking you how how to
proceed when one train of thought is
that everything that's written in the
Constitution is the only way to decide
cases and they are the only people that
understand the Constitution well I I
don't believe that Supreme Court
justices have a monopoly on
constitutional wisdom in fact my whole
view of government is is based on the
opposite which is that each branch of
government has its own obligation to
think hard about the Constitution and
what it means and what its own role is
in fact one of the things I blame the
Bush administration for the most in its
approach to Guantanamo is that I while
it's convenient for the executive to say
we should have totally unreviewable
discretion over all these detainees it's
bad for the Republic that case should
never have gone to the court because the
executive branch should have thought
about its own constitutional role more
carefully than it did in the Senate they
have the obligation to think about their
constitutional vision which is why I'm
not someone who thinks it's enough it's
great that John Roberts is it's super
brainy is a apparently an extremely
decent man is really well credentialed
but ultimately senators have to ask
themselves is he right or is he wrong
with my vision of the Constitution and
the courts role in it and they have to
vote on that basis not just is he a good
guy sir ask you a couple questions one
what effect do you think this recent
case in the state of Missouri where a
gentleman I believe his name is Larry
Griffin he was put to death he's already
dead but now the case is being reopened
by the prosecuting attorney and even the
family of the victim has come out
publicly saying that they think they've
killed the wrong man and this may be the
first
acknowledged public case worse they've
killed the wrong man could this possibly
have an effect on the court now that as
you know in the state of Illinois
Governor George Ryan canceled all death
penalty so the system was cleaned up
what effect you think they might have
possibly on future cases brought before
the court and also the second case of
eminent domain which has become very
very controversial yes about the
government being able to confiscate
property I'll repeat the question
he asked two questions one of which I'll
summarize which is there's now a case of
demonstrated innocence of a man who's
been executed what effect will that have
and then he asked about the eminent
domain case the kilo case from New
London Connecticut let me start with the
death penalty I DNA has provided DNA
testing and evidence has provided an
audit of our capital punishment system
and as people in Illinois have
recognized people around the country are
recognizing that audit has come back
with some very very troubling results
and now the most troubling of all is
coming out in this new case because the
other people were found innocent while
they were still on death row and now
we're going to find somebody turn out
somebody was innocent who's actually
been executed the worst of all possible
circumstances it has shaken people up on
the court in the middle O'Connor and
Kennedy and of course O'Connor is going
to be gone now but they're troubled
they're deeply troubled by by this issue
of innocence if you had asked them when
I was there how many people do you think
are on death row who are really innocent
I just confident the answer would have
come back oh it's hardly anybody and
that's just these new these new evidence
cases that's that's just a bunch of
trumped-up stuff now they know that that
was wrong and they and it's bothering
them and that's why you saw them and you
know they haven't quite gotten around
knowing what to do about it but there's
greater skepticism you saw the miller-el
case they sent a case back the juvenile
death penalty case the mentally [ __ ]
case all of a sudden there's shift and
it's because of the innocence movement
my view on on the on the kilo case from
New London which is this case where I
the the elected representatives in New
London basically handed
condemned houses and we're handing it
over to a private developer to Bill in
this case a pharmaceutical company a
very very tricky case I think for for
both sides but let I think the the key
issue is what does the Constitution say
and it says that you cannot take private
property for a public use without paying
just compensation and the question is
who is going to decide what a public use
is in the past the answer has always
been very straightforward which is I
it's got to be the elected legislature
that's that's what you elect them for to
decide what the public purpose is and
that's really where the majority came
out on this case but the the facts of
this case we're so troubling that
because it seemed like such a just a
direct transfer of property from person
a to person B without a whole lot of
thinking about what exactly the public
benefit was going to be that it's gotten
people concerned about that but I think
at the end of the day it's very hard for
you to say some judge is going to
substitute his or her judgment about
what a public use is to the elected
officials the answer has to be they do
things like that you got a voter matter
office that's that's what democracy is
for rather than the substitution of
unelected views for elected views as
sympathetic as I am to the plaintiffs in
that case but that's that's a this
question is one that's going to come up
over and over again thank you mr.
Blackman had to be brought to work and
home in a limousine I understand with a
bodyguard because of death threats
against him dealing with the ROE case
and I used to see mr. Rehnquist walk
around the Supreme Court just with his
law clerks did you comment on that well
actually he didn't get that much private
protection Blackmun didn't it he did
occasionally when he traveled but he was
brought back and forth by a driver when
he was in his 80s for for other reasons
other than just security or maybe it was
a security of a different kind yes sir
very insightful talk i had read an
article a few weeks ago in legal affairs
magazine criticizing justice Blackmun
which would painted a contrasting
picture to the meticulousness that you
had described and I was wondering if you
could comment on that also
I found interesting your comment about
the justices who automatically would
rule against the death penalty
I had read of the instance of Justice
Douglas would automatically rule against
the Internal Revenue Service and never
ruled in favor of the Internal Revenue
Service which I felt was inappropriate
is there any other recent example of
justices taking if you will an automatic
position in certain instances I can't
think of another instance where someone
has been that automatic where it's just
flat out and I have to go look at the
record about justice Douglas we were
honored here to have one of the earliest
colleagues of Justice Douglas in the
room David Ginsburg one of the great
lawyers of our time I don't know there
he can shed any light on that but but
it's wonderful to see David but in terms
of justice Blackmun the controversy
you're referring to is there have been
articles written now that Blackmun's
papers are open that he delegated much
much too much responsibility to law
clerks to draft his opinions and I have
mixed views both intellectual and
emotional on the topic I think it is
fair to say that a number of members of
the Supreme Court of recent time have
delegated too much responsibility to
young law clerks like myself 28 years
old I sometimes not always with the
wisdom to carry out our duties as well
as we should and I think justice
Blackmun was guilty of that I don't
think he was as guilty of that as the
recent articles have suggested and I'm
not sure why that journalist is on quite
the vendetta he is but I will say that
there is a danger in having law clerk
who do the drafts of opinions and the
danger is that once a draft is
established those of us who make our
living as writers know that unless you
have someone who's editing by ripping
the whole thing apart things get in
there that maybe don't get thought
through as carefully as they should and
any practitioner knows Supreme Court
opinions in this country are
ward over for their every nuance which
words they use in every particular and
when those are crafted too often by law
clerks without sufficient supervision
there's a problem and I do think that
sometimes although he was meticulous I
mean he he site checked every one of his
own opinions justice Blackmun did but
sometimes too much of that intellectual
content did come from law clerks and I
do write about this in the book fact I
was roundly criticized for having
suggested that law clerks played too big
a role but but they do thank you for
your whole discussion of this and
helping demystify the closed chambers I
want to ask you about the Commerce
Clause because when you were a clerk it
was less in play than it is now and
since then the court at times has done
something that many of us thought was
settled with the coming of the New Deal
and after after justice black and others
got on the court of deferring to
Congress's judgment on the findings of
what affects interstate commerce there
seems to be Judge Roberts seems to have
a lot of skepticism about the fairing to
Congress and I hope as a lawyer you
would help guide us through some of the
questions that you think the Judiciary
Committee should be asking of Judge
Roberts on the Commerce Clause that that
was as articulate and thoughtful and
knowledgeable a question is I think I'll
ever receive and I thank you for it
and and in fact the Commerce Clause
cases are one of the lines of cases I
feature in the new chapter for just the
reason you say which is that the
federalism revolution was just getting
started when I was there as a law clerk
you could see it coming but you couldn't
quite tell how far it was going to go
and the basic paradigm you've described
is exactly right which is in the New
Deal the question was what are
Congress's powers to to regulate
interstate commerce and how much local
stuff can you get I and and and pretty
much from the New Deal on
the answer to that question was it's
really up to Congress to figure all that
out and the states to the extent that
they feel their ox is gored they have a
say in Congress and there is a political
solution to this which is in this house
in the Senate this Court has taken a
different view of that it has started to
put limits on what Congress can do and
started to second-guess Congress's
findings under the Commerce Clause and
it is struck down parts of some federal
statutes on that basis now the question
is there's not a lot it hasn't mattered
that much yet but it's really a question
of how much further it's going to go and
the reason that's important is the
Commerce Clause Congress can't just do
whatever it wants Congress needs a
constitutional hook for its power and
the Commerce Clause has been the hook
for a lot of very very important stuff
including a lot of the major civil
rights acts of the 1960s because why is
it that you can outlaw private
discrimination at lunch counters in the
south well the answer was because food
goes in interstate commerce that's a bit
of an oversimplification but this is the
way a lot of important things worker
safety and lots of other things get done
that feel local now John Roberts why is
he a question mark well in conservative
legal circles there is something called
the Constitution in exile movement and
the Constitution and Exile movement is
basically a free enterprise small
government movement that wants to think
very differently about the New Deal and
about the commerce clause in particular
and what we don't know is where does
John Roberts stand all on all this he
wrote a dissent from a denial of a
petition for rehearing on bonk that's a
very complicated way of saying it in
federal courts you get your first
hearing in front of three judges and if
you don't like how they came out
you can petition for a hearing from the
full court of appeals that's called a
petition for rehearing on bunk and every
once in a while in an unusual case a
court will turn down one of those
petitions and one or two of the judges
will write something to send up a signal
flare saying I think this is a really
interesting issue and I want you to
bring this back to me
and john roberts sent up a signal flare
in a case involving the endangered
species act in which he suggested that
the commerce clause was not a ska was a
constitutional hook to which the
Endangered Species Act could not be
placed that's an awkward way of putting
it but I think you get my point
and he called into question the
constitutionality of the Endangered
Species Act the question is okay why did
he think that because he doesn't say and
what else would be affected by his
thinking and where is he on a broader
range of issues having to do with
national power because there's nothing
more important at the court right now
than this question on which with
O'Connor leaving the court really is
divided four to four
today like a lot of occasions where
there's a question-and-answer period
until recent minutes there was no woman
in line to ask any questions now the
court has just lost Sandra Day O'Connor
unless Rehnquist croaks and she gets
appointed to this to the head you know
but there is a problem that I'm
wondering about and that is that if
you're not in line is somebody's
presuming that women don't count they're
their brains don't count and you know we
can't have that kind of an assumption
going on all over the place if if that's
what's happening because of course there
won't be another female just
disappointed if if that's so so I'm
wondering what you think about the
importance of having a more balance
between men and women on the Supreme
Court overall I think diversity on the
court is very important but I will say
this about President Bush I think it's
very case that he's not genuinely
committed to both gender and other forms
of diversity
anybody who knows my writing knows I'm
I'm not a fan of the president but you
can't have Condoleezza Rice as your
Secretary of State running around the
Middle East right now and not think the
man believes women are every bit as
capable of carrying out high position as
men I don't you know I don't know of
course what the decisional process was
that brought them to John Roberts he's
someone who's been highly highly
respected in the law for a long time
even though he's a young man I there
certainly were excellent women
candidates out there and it wouldn't
surprise me at all if Chief Justice
Rehnquist were to retire that he would
feel that he should put another woman on
the court and it would be wonderful to
have
or women on the court whether it's going
to be a democratic or republican
administration putting them up there it
would also be wonderful to have Hispanic
we haven't had one and I have also
written I'm no fan of the current
Attorney General because of his work on
the torture memos but there other
Hispanics out there who should have
gotten serious consideration it's it's
important for people of not not only
gender and ethnic diversity but a
diversity of views beyond that court a
diversity of approaches it's a we all
benefit from the debate that goes on
there if it's a real debate and if it's
the sound of one hand clapping that's
not worth very much there's just one
thing
besides being wonderful I think that you
would find that a lot of women would
have varying viewpoints from a lot of
men on a lot of issues and that's why I
think it's important it's certainly true
that that to some extent diversity
brings a diversity of views but there
were lots of women out there who
probably had the same jurisprudential
views as john roberts who could have
been selected so it's just like Clarence
Thomas and Thurgood Marshall or nothing
alike either so I'm a little I feel
there's there's some risk there of
sinking into a certain amount of
stereotype I I think over the long run
you'll see more and more women on the
court because more and more of the great
lawyers in America being produced by the
law schools today are going to be women
it's just really a matter of catching up
by time the profession has radically
changed as I seem in my own office every
day and and the women are at the top of
the profession all over the place now
and they'll be on that Court two other
questions we have a woman in life
different approach to arriving at
decisions that perhaps precipitated the
breach between justice Blackmun and
justice burger
yes Linda greenhouse in her new book has
talked about the rift that grew between
justice burger and justice blackmun they
they were best friends in Minnesota from
childhood of Blackman was burgers best
man at his wedding and they had
supported each other in letters
throughout their respective careers my
own theory about that is that by the
time the Blackman was put on the court
in some ways that friendship had rotten
rotted beneath the waterline people
didn't know it even though I don't even
think the protagonists knew it
but burger had come to Washington stayed
in Washington had been put on the DC
Circuit which was a very polarized court
had become very bitter towards his
liberal colleagues on that court and and
it had grown much more conservative in
isolation from Blackmon who was in the
Midwest who really still had a lot of
liberal personal values just like his
personal opposition to the death penalty
when he got to the court and I think
when they grew into that close proximity
they realized they'd grown into near
opposites in some ways burger had put on
it came you know bought a Country Estate
you know really left a lot of that
behind Blackman living a little
three-bedroom apartment drove a VW Bug
they had become very very different
people and in that hydraulically sealed
pressurized environment of the court
their personalities and these
differences of view just rubbed up
against each other in a way that
exploded it as speaking of since we're
talking about gender things I'll tell if
you don't mind it's a small anecdote
about that I I remember Blackman telling
us one time at breakfast there had been
an oral argument where a woman had come
to argue a case wearing an extremely
elegant pantsuit instead of a regular
you know dress and blouse suit whatever
I know what the other kind is called
even and this had infuriated burger and
he had turned his back on the woman and
that was the kind of thing Blackman was
such a down-to-earth person aside from
having three daughters I mean I just you
know there were things like that that
just stuck with him part of it also I
think was that burger was rather
half-hearted in his support of roe
drifted from roe Blackmun was very
defensive about the
opinion I think greenhouse does a good
job describing that in her book and I'm
sure that that politics inside the court
also played a role but a remarkable
story of of two friends who became
strangers if not enemies yes a lot of
people in the country think that you
know we're quote on the wrong track and
whether you're liberal conservative you
probably ascribe different reasons for
that but I think for conservatives
that's some Supreme Court opinions
probably starting with brown and other
private earlier than that row and said
the sodomy decision did you sense when
you were on the court that there was any
concern about whether the court is
getting too far ahead of or outside of
mainstream of public opinion and do they
care to lead the country or you know I
mean were they concerned about that I
think the irony of this court actually
is despite it's incredibly deep
divisions over the last fifteen or
twenty years
oddly enough they've kind of ended up
with a majority of Americans they don't
please the extremes but the funny part
because O'Connor O'Connor's have
controlled the court she's a non radical
conservative I so on Roe vs. Wade it's
cut back I yes there's a right but
there's lots of state regulation prayer
and that kind of stuff a lot more
religion on entanglement with the state
allowed but there's kind of limit no
prayer in the schools and I on lots of
issue of these social issues I think the
court has probably you know put itself
where most Americans are and it gets
caught in the crossfire between the
right and the left that's not to say
that a mushy centralism is a good thing
for the court because i would argue that
a lot of those opinions don't have any
principle behind them except for trying
to place the court in the center but i i
think a lot of the flack the court has
taken is is really not from the center
of the spectrum but from either the
right or or the left that's my that's my
sense of it but row of course has been a
tremendously polarizing decision and
Bush v Gore tremendously polarizing
decision I and and that's why to me the
court role is not to please but to
persuade and this Court does not
persuade very well forgive me I'm rising
here not to question you but to deliver
a gift Jo vraal was a classmate and he
and he remained we remained friends for
all of our lives and I'm sure that they
were in this store often Jo and Olli
last week only sent me the text of two
speeches that Joe gave at the University
of California in San Diego this was 1990
he really deals with decisions of the
court that concern him from reading the
nine old men to Rehnquist actually
Rehnquist was on the court as an
Associate Justice at the time and he
commented on some of the actions taken
and later on how he changed his
attitudes as he became Chief Justice I
think you'll be interested in reading it
and I here was give you the text only
sent it to me just last week and I'm
happy to bring it here to you well I'm
honored I for those of you who don't
know Joe Rao was one of the the great
lawyers of the 20th century one of the
leading civil rights lawyers in this
country and this gentleman David
Ginsburg also preeminent in the field
and it is an honor to receive this I
thank you and I think everyone for
listening this is this talk will be a
memory I'll carry with me for a long
time
your book sign sign hot lot up here and
with